die frau sondierungen mit der fdp und
den grünen waren gute konstruktive
gespräche wir haben klar anerkannt dass
es eine neue situation für die
regierungsbildung gibt wir haben die
wahl nicht gewonnen wir haben nicht
platz eins sondern platz zwei und wir
erkennen an dass fdp und grüne
entscheiden mit wem sondiert wird wer
mit den gesprächen die zahlreichen
gemeinsamkeiten aufgezeigt dagegen
setzten die bereitschaft zum kompromiss
signalisiert
und unseren willen und unsere lust für
ein neues politik projekt deutlich
gemacht dass wurde im nachgang auch von
fdp und grünen bestätigt aber es geht
jetzt nicht darum welche partei oder
welche person in die regierung kommt
sondern welche politik die nächsten vier
jahre gemacht wird das ist der grund
weshalb ich mich für jamaika einsätze
jamaika ist die chance für einen echten
aufbruch in unserem land aber wer ein
ambitioniertes modernisierungs bündnis
mit breiter gesellschaftlicher
verankerung zur micah hat mit der union
einen anker vor ort in den städten und
gemeinden in den ländlichen räumen in
den urbanen räumen in ost und west in
der wirtschaft beim handwerk bei der
landwirtschaft bei jung und alt
und jamaika hat einen starken partner im
bundesrat schalker könnte eine menge
sehr schnell umsetzen mit cdu fdp cdu
grünen und jamaica regierungen und wenn
es fdp und grüne um einen aufbruch und
ambition geht ist die spd der falsche
partner das können wir aus langjährige
regierungserfahrung
bestätigen vor diesem hintergrund gibt
es zumindest berechtigte fragen warum
ohne not in einseitige
sondierungsgespräche gestartet worden
ist wir von uns schlagen keine tür zur
entscheidungsgrundlage
einer regierung für vier jahre in dieser
situation
müssen die ziele der nächsten vier jahre
sein und nicht tagesaktuelle stimmungen
und in diesem sinne das angebot der cdu
deutschlands steht bis zur letzten
sekunde der regierungsbildung
und die gründe von
fdp und grünen die jamaica optionen auch
für möglich erachtet haben gelten weiter
und deshalb
werden wir jetzt genau beobachten wie
die vertieften gespräche zu denen fdp
und grüne sich heute für die nächste
woche verabredet haben wie die verlaufen
wie das beispielsweise in der steuer
finanz und haushaltspolitik
funktionieren soll die fdp war für eine
absenkung der unternehmenssteuer um
wettbewerbsfähigkeit zu erhöhen um
arbeitsplätze zu sichern für die
abschaffung des solidaritätszuschlags
für erweiterte und beschleunigte
abschreibung gegen eine vermögenssteuer
für die beibehaltung des
ehegattensplittings gegen eine
schuldenunion für die einhaltung der
schuldenbremse und und und und deshalb
werden wir sehr aufmerksam in der
nächsten woche die beratungen verfolgen
das gleiche gilt für die
mitarbeiterbeteiligung beispielsweise
bei startups eine ganz wichtige frage
für die start up kultur und start up
szene ebenso wie beim bürokratieabbau
entfesselung alles themen die in den
letzten jahren der großen koalition
mühsam mit der fdp mit der spd zu
bewegen waren
das gleiche gilt beim klimaschutz wir
brauchen mehr tempo und
deshalb werden wir mit unseren ideen
bereit stehen aber
viele zitieren immer immer wieder diesen
spruch erst das land dann die partei
dann die person bei dem thema könnte man
das einmal belegen wo ist die größte
stabilität möglich
und wir signalisieren
fdp und grünen
ansprechpartner für die cdu bleibt der
cdu vorsitzende dafür habe ich die
rückendeckung von partei und fraktion
und es wird nicht am ansprechpartner
scheitern wenn man ein neues projekt
beginnt es gibt wertschätzung auch in
den persönlichen gesprächen von fdp und
grünen gegenüber meiner person aber ich
habe bereits in den gesprächen deutlich
gemacht an der person wird es nicht
scheitern
und das habe ich heute auch der fraktion
berichtet es geht nicht um die person
armin laschet es geht um das projekt für
das land und deshalb wenn man zu anderen
lösungen kommen will ist dies möglich
das große projekt jamaica wird nicht am
personal scheitern wird nicht an
einzelnen personen scheitern es ist eine
große aufgabe vor der wir stehen und
dieses signal ist
bereits in den gesprächen dieser woche
übermittelt worden ist auch im unions
internen kreis übermittelt worden und
die darüber habe ich heute der fraktion
berichtet das ist der prozess
regierungsbildung jamaika eine andere
frage ist die frage welche konsequenzen
zieht die cdu aus dem wahlergebnis
sowohl für die theoretische möglichkeit
einer regierungsbeteiligung als auch für
die möglichkeit der opposition und wir
müssen dieses wahlergebnis aufarbeiten
und die neuaufstellung der cdu
vorantreiben meine feste überzeugung
bleibt dabei
erneuerungen geht auch in der regierung
geht sogar besser in der regierung geht
aber auch in der opposition und zur
aufarbeitung des wahlergebnisses hat
generalsekretär zenit bereits ein
maßnahmenpaket mit den generalsekretären
der landesparteien
geschlossen er steht zum dialog bereit
er wird den online konferenzen und vor
ort präsent sein in den landesverbänden
werden im november eine ost konferenz
veranstalten um die besonderen
strukturellen fragen des ostens wo die
afg unser größter gegner ist und wo wir
alles tun wollen sie wieder
zurückzudrängen wie das gelingen kann
wir werden darüber hinaus im dezember zu
einer kreisvorsitzendenkonferenz
einladen und wir werden eine interne
kommission zur aufarbeitung einsätzen in
der ehemalige und amtierende
bundestagsabgeordnete beteiligt sind
sowie mitglieder aus den landesverbänden
auch sachverstand von außen der einmal
genau analysieren wird was ist denn in
den letzten jahren schief gelaufen wo
müssen wir besser werden wo müssen wir
programmatisch besser werden wo müssen
wir im vorpolitischen raum besser werden
alle diese fragen gehören zur
aufarbeitung des wahlergebnisses
zur personellen zukunft und
neuaufstellung werde ich den gremien der
partei der kommenden woche die
einberufung eines parteitags vorschlagen
das ist der ort wo die 1001 delegierten
aus allen kreisverbänden sich
artikulieren können ort und datum werden
wir noch gemeinsam festlegen
und die personelle frage die dann an
steht braucht andere wege braucht
vielleicht
unkonventionelle wege wir haben seit
2008 10 seit dem rückzug von angela
merkel als parteivorsitzende
eine andauernde personaldebatte
er lebt immer gegeneinander immer in
wechselnden besetzungen und
wir wollen diesmal einen anderen weg
gehen wir wollen einen weg des konsenses
gehen und jeder ist auch klug sich jetzt
daran zu halten
in nordrhein westfalen in einem großen
landesverband der lange zerstritten war
ist dass in den letzten tagen gelungen
es gab mehrere interessenten für das amt
des landesvorsitzenden und des
ministerpräsidenten
oder der ministerpräsidentin und wir
haben in intensiven gesprächen erreicht
dass am ende alle auch die die eigene
interessen hatten die zurückgestellt
haben und sich auf einen kandidaten
verständigt der nun ende oktober zum
neuen ministerpräsidenten in nordrhein
westfalen und damit auch zum
vorsitzenden des größten landesverbandes
in der cdu gewählt werden soll mit
hendrik wüst und dieses beispiel
wollen wir auch in der bundes partei
versuchen einen konsens aller die im
moment in betracht kommen diesen prozess
werde ich moderieren und hierzu will ich
bereits in den kommenden wochen mit den
landesvorsitzenden der partei
beraten um auch da zu hören wie denkt
denn die jeweilige basis über diesen
künftigen prozess
welches profil soll denn dieser kandidat
oder diese kandidatin haben und kann es
uns nicht diesmal gelingen dass wir eine
gemeinsame lösung für die aufstellung in
der opposition finden der wunsch danach
an der basis ist sehr groß das ziel dies
zu erreichen ist eine ambitionierte
aufgabe die ich mir vorgenommen habe
fazit in drei sätzen die cdu steht
weiter für jamaika bereit
wir arbeiten das wahlergebnis bereits
jetzt in der nächsten zeit intensiv auf
die personelle neuaufstellung
der cdu
vom vorsitzenden über das präsidium bis
hinein in den bundesvorstand werden wir
ebenfalls zügig anpacken mein ziel ist
es was immer in meinem leben mein ziel
war gegensätze zu versöhnen zu einer
gemeinsamkeit zu kommen
in unserem namen union ist das enthalten
und ich wäre froh
wenn das in dieser schwierigen phase für
die partei gelingen würde dass wir mit
neuen persönlichkeiten einen neuanfang
machen ob am ende in regierung oder in
opposition ist dabei nicht die wichtige
frage die wichtige frage ist das eine
bürgerliche starke
volkspartei in europa
zu neuen erfolgen kommt und mit neuem
elan ihren beitrag leistet zur zukunft
des landes vielen dank
ja und wir sind wieder hier das ja ist
auch von mir ein bisschen verwirrung
nicht nur deswegen weil die kollegen
offenbar alles schon davon ausgehen dass
es hier einen rücktritt gibt sondern
auch vielleicht ein bisschen
überraschung über den auftritt von armin
laschet er hat ja begonnen mit der
sondierung und das resümee aus dem was
er geschrieben hat war wir stehen bereit
für jamaica das wissen wir dass das so
ist dass er das jetzt noch mal betont
hat muss ein bisschen überraschen denn
das was wir vorher gesehen haben war ja
eine relativ große einigkeit der drei
die da heute sondiert haben das zweite
war die konsequenzen für die cdu und die
personellen konsequenzen
das hat er angedeutet dass das passieren
wird aber wir wissen nicht was das
konkret heißt
ich würde sagen herkommen das kann man
noch eine wendung dazwischen oder noch
titel nach noch etwas anderes er hat ja
dann gesagt und ich habe das mandat für
diese gespräche denn ich habe das
vertrauen ich stehe an der spitze dieser
partei und da war tatsächlich die
verwirrungen extrem groß weil man ja im
vorfeld davon ausgehen musste hier wird
klar ein rücktritt verkünden verkündet
und das ist ja
man muss jetzt exegese betreiben was für
politische kommunikation immer ja
schwierig ist ich habe am ende schon
raus gehört ganz klar personelle
neuaufstellung alle gliederungen alle
gremien
parteivorstand einschließlich des
vorsitzenden
es geht um einen prozess der jetzt
initiiert werden soll und der mündet
auch in einen eine personelle
neuaufstellung
das schließt an den vorsitzenden ja
ausdrücklich mit ein insofern ja was ist
das jetzt eine
ankündigung so auf raten so sukzessive
aber jetzt nicht unmittelbar
es ist in der anlage dieser
pressekonferenz etwas verwirrend das
muss man schon sagen ja wir sind alle
glaube ich ein bisschen ratlos weil das
heißt ja auch dass man sich im prinzip
aus dem wettbewerb mit den anderen
portalen heraus manövriert hat wir haben
eine dokumentation einstweilen für sie
mit dem schönen namen groß krisen und
kompromisse denn darum geht es natürlich
im augenblick auch denken sie daran 23
uhr sind wir wieder da und
möglicherweise zwar nicht mit ganz neuen
neuigkeiten aber das was man heutzutage
nie bis nachher